aquí tenemos la función fx igual a x
menos 1 al cuadrado menos 2 para x menor
o igual que 1 la gráfica de esta función
con esta restricción es media parábola y
lo que queremos hacer es encontrar la
inversa de f quiero que pienses por su
cuenta porque estamos pidiendo esta
restricción que dificultades tendríamos
para encontrar la inversa si no la
tuviéramos para bueno déjame empezar a
encontrar la inversa lo primero que
tenemos que hacer es tomar una variable
e igualar la fx que es igual a x
cuadrada x menos 1 al cuadrado menos 2
lo voy a escribir aquí que es igual a x
menos 1 al cuadrado menos 2 y voy a
escribir la restricción para
para x menor o igual que 1 menor o igual
que uno muy bien esto lo que nos da es
una forma de poner allí en términos de x
y sabemos que x tiene cierta restricción
ahora si vemos la gráfica también
sabemos que ya tiene cierta restricción
aquí en el dibujo se puede ver que ye
siempre es mayor o igual que menos 2
entonces también voy a escribir esa
restricción pero entre paréntesis ye
mayor o igual que menos 2 que menos 2
para indicar que es una una restricción
que tenemos a partir de como está
definido hoy e incluso se puede ver aquí
en esta expresión verdad esto de aquí
siempre es mayor o igual que 0 entonces
siempre es mayor o igual que menos 2
después cuando tengamos a la inversa a
la función inversa en términos de y
entonces esto se va a convertir en una
restricción para el dominio déjame
empezar a despejar y sumando dos de
ambos lados tenemos que ye más 2 es
igual
x menos 1 al cuadrado para para y aquí
como ya no es muy claro cuál es la
variable dependiente igual la
independiente voy a poner esta fuera
esta restricción para mayor o igual que
menos 2 y voy a poner esta en paréntesis
y para x menor o igual que 1 el
siguiente paso sería sacar raíz cuadrada
pero aquí hay que tener especial cuidado
sacar raíz cuadrada así de golpe no
estaría totalmente mal pero sí estaría
mal
o séase que sacar raíz cuadrada pero
recuerda que siempre cuando sacamos raíz
cuadrada de una expresión tenemos que
cuidar si la raíz que debemos considerar
es la positiva o la negativa entonces
aquí probablemente vas a ver algo con lo
cual nunca te has encontrado antes
entonces presta especial atención
observa que nos están diciendo que x es
menor o igual que uno entonces x menos 1
es negativo verdad aquí podemos restar
uno de ambos lados y x menos uno queda
menor o igual que cero entonces al sacar
raíz cuadrada del lado izquierdo
debemos de tomar la raíz negativa déjame
hacer un ejemplo aquí con números para
que veas a qué me refiero si tenemos
menos 3
y lo elevamos al cuadrado eso es igual a
9 ahora imagínate que queremos sacar
raíz cuadrada y recuperar este menos 3
si sacamos la raíz cuadrada la raíz
cuadrada así de menos 3 elevado al
cuadrado y la raíz cuadrada de 9 y no
somos cuidadosos y tomamos la raíz
positiva entonces de este lado o de este
lado si quieres la raíz de 9 nos va a
quedar igual a 3 y acá también nos va a
quedar igual a 3 y no recuperamos el
menos 3 para recuperar el menos 3
debemos de considerar la raíz negativa
de 9 está la raíz principal que es la
positiva que simplemente es 3 pero hay
otro número que al elevarlo al cuadrado
también da 9 y ese es menos 3 entonces
este mismo fenómeno es el fenómeno que
va a pasar aquí como tenemos que x menos
1 es menor o igual que 0 al sacar raíz a
la izquierda debemos considerar la raíz
negativa entonces nos quedaría menos
menos la raíz de yemas 2
es igual a y aquí sacamos raíz es igual
a la raíz cuadrada
la raíz cuadrada de x menos 1 al
cuadrado ok entonces aquí nos quedaría
menos la raíz cuadrada de yemas 2
ye más dos es igual a equis menos uno y
observa que todo va bien observa que
aquí tenemos un número negativo que es
menos raíz de yemas 2 y aquí también x
menos uno es menor o igual que cero por
esta restricción déjame escribir las
restricciones aquí sería para
para
mayor o igual que menos 2 y aquí x menor
o igual que 1 y aquí también le voy a
poner para bueno ahorita ya me voy a
olvidar de la restricción de x porque ya
estamos muy cerca de que esto sea una
función de y entonces para ye mayor o
igual que menos 2 muy bien y observa que
esta restricción es importante para
poder sacar esta raíz cuadrada voy a
seguir despejando sumo uno de ambos
lados y me queda menos raíz cuadrada de
yemas dos más uno es igual a equis voy a
invertir esta igualdad para que se vea
un poco más como como una función de y
entonces x es igual a menos la raíz
cuadrada de ye más dos
+ 1 y esto lo podemos poner en notación
de funciones si tenemos que
originalmente esta era fx ponemos que
efe a la menos uno evaluado en jeff es
igual a menos la raíz cuadrada de de que
dos más uno muy bien y aquí se puede
cambiar está por cualquier otra variable
es bueno ponerla como x es bueno ponerla
como x pues para verla un poco mejor
como como función y para que sea un poco
más fácil de entender cómo se grafica
entonces simplemente voy a retirar esta
variable y como x me queda que f inversa
de x es igual a menos la raíz cuadrada
de y no de x porque cambie todas las 10
por x de x + 2
+ 1 y listo aquí tenemos la función
inversa y con esta expresión podemos
graficar la podemos graficar la déjame
tomar el color rosa el color rosa para
graficar la y vamos a tomar algunos
puntos muestra ahora cuáles son las
restricciones recuerda que siempre james
es mayor o igual que menos 2 entonces
aquí también hay que ponerle para
mayor o igual a no aquí es x verdad
porque la variable ya es x para x mayor
o igual que menos 2 todos éstos serían
para ye mayor o igual que menos 2 y aquí
es para x mayor o igual que menos 2 y
ahora sí tomando puntos muestra pues
digamos si x es igual a menos 2 esto es
0 así que nos queda 1 voy a graficar lo
por aquí entonces en menos 2 el valor es
luego para x igual a menos 1 esta
expresión es raíz es menos raíz de 16
menos 11 que nos da 0 entonces
tendríamos este punto en la gráfica y
luego si le pongo x igualados me
quedaría raíz de 4 que es 2 menos dos
más uno es menos uno entonces para x
igualados el valor de la función es
menos uno y ahí ya tenemos tres puntos
con los cuales podemos más o menos
graficar la inversa que se vería algo de
este estilo
algo de
este estilo bueno
algo así me queda un poquito hecho acá
pero bueno
algo así sería una parábola pero con un
acostada sale muy bien ya finalmente
pues nada más hay que hay que verificar
que se cumple lo que hemos estado
repitiendo desde el inicio que esta
gráfica y esta gráfica son el reflejo
una de la otra con respecto a la gráfica
de la función e igual a equis que voy a
dibujar por aquí para que veas que en
efecto una es una versión en espejo de
la otra vale bueno creo que este es de
los problemas más difíciles que te
puedes encontrar para en esta en esta
área o en este tema de calcular inversos
y lo que lo hace especialmente difícil
es esta parte truculenta en la cual al
sacar la raíz cuadrada
la raíz cuadrada debemos considerar la
raíz negativa ba bueno entonces vamos a
dejarle hasta aquí espero que estos
ejemplos te hayan servido para entender
las funciones inversas